So, back to our overall
reducing the AMAT.
We've seen some techniques
to reduce the hit time.
We've seen techniques to
reduce the miss rate.
We've seen a technique for
reducing the miss penalty which
is to overlap multiple misses.
And we will now see a technique
called multi-level caches, or
having a cache hierarchy
instead of just one cache.
With this technique, a miss in the first
cache of the processor accesses,
which is called now a level one cache,
will just go to another
cache instead of memory.
So now, the miss penalty from
our level one cache is not
equal to the memory latency.
The miss penalty in level one
cache now is the hit time
of the level two cache plus when
the level two cache misses,
then it's going to be level two miss
rate times the level two miss penalty.
And this level two miss penalty can be
the actual memory latency but we can
have a level three cache and if we miss
there, a level four cache and so on.